This particular chart-based approach
is due to Jay Earley,
a computer scientist and psychologist.
And now that we've seen all the theory behind it,
we're going to code it up in Python together.
Now one of the tricks that's different between this and Memo_Fibo
is that our chart may have many things in it.
One of the differences between this chart-based algorithm
and our memoized Fibonacci
is that our charts hold groups--lists, sets--of items.
After we've seen one token of input,
there's an entire collection of parse states that we could be in.
So we're going to represent that
by having our chart be a dictionary
that maps from numbers to lists.
But we're going to use those lists--
we don't really want any duplicates,
Just like we saw with Memo_Fibo,
we want to keep adding things to the chart until we're done.
We want to be lazy and not do any extra work.
So I don't want to add any duplicate entries to the chart
because that'll just be more work for me to do later,
and it may not settle down.
So I'm going to write a special Add procedure,
treating the right-hand side of the chart
as if it were a set.
And you may have seen sets in mathematics,
but if you haven't a list can have elements repeated.
I can have this list: [1, 2, 2, 3].
But in a set, each element can occur, at most, once.
So if I were to put:  into this set,
I would just get:  as the final result.
When you're about to put something in, you check and see if it's already there,
and if it's already there, you don't do anything.
I'm going to have you implement that set for me.
What I'd like you to do
is write a Python procedure, using the Interpreter
called: addtochart
that takes 3 arguments: the chart,
a Python dictionary, the index, a number,
and the state--more on that later, but it could be anything--
and it ensures that if I go look at chart[index] later,
it will return a list--it will evaluate to a list--
that contains state exactly once.
So if state was already in chart[index], don't do anything.
If it wasn't, you want to add it.
addtochart should return true
if something was actually added to chart[index],
and return False otherwise--
False if if was already there.
And we're going to us this so that we can tell if we actually updated the chart
and then if we didn't update the chart,maybe we're closer to being done.
To simplify this problem bit, you can assume
that chart[index] is valid--that index is already in this mapping
and that it returns a list.
Let's say it's the Empty list, if we haven't gotten started yet.
But it's, at least, going to be a list. Go forth!